if you're a fan of anime then you should
know that one of the best New Gen series
is about to drop and in this video I'll
be explaining everything you need to
know Marshall is a show that takes heavy
inspiration from the comedic tone of one
punch man the magic of Harry Potter and
as a main character who was partly
influenced by jotaro Kujo in my opinion
if you're a fan of JoJo's my hero Black
Clover or any of the things I already
mentioned then there's a high chance
you're probably gonna like this series
as well that being said in case you're
still not sure about everything then
let's dive into all the reasons why you
should check it out okay so Marshall is
set in a Magic based society where
nearly everyone is born with a magic
mark on their face as you can see the
marks come in different shapes and sizes
and while most humans are born with just
one line any child born with two lines
is considered to have an insane amount
of magic potential on average out of
every 100 000 people only one will be a
double line magic user and people with
three lines are even more difficult to
find this is what brings us to Eastern
Academy which is a super prestige just
magic school based off Hogwarts where
the best of the best learn to become
Wizards what's important to know about
this place is that each student gets
placed into one of these three houses
and most of the characters that we care
about are in House Adler historically
Adler is basically like Gryffindor in
that it represents bravery and
conviction and it's normal for people in
this house to have good intentions
behind why they do what they do by
contrast house Lang represents ambition
and talent and many of the students here
come from Rich families who value the
importance of Bloodlines above
everything else in season 1 of Marshall
one of the most interesting things that
we'll see is how the Rivalry develops
between Lang and Adler because all the
different houses are fighting for one
thing each year a single student from
Easton is chosen to become the Divine
Visionary which is a title that almost
everybody wants for their own reasons
the Divine Visionary is a student said
to be chosen by God himself and the
title comes with wealth status and a
leadership position inside the Bureau of
Magic the Bureau of magic are the ones
to essentially decide how Society is run
and so any character who wants to change
the world in some way they need to
become a Divine Visionary before their
time at Easton is over this means that
the Rivalry between Lang and Adler will
impact the future of the whole country
since you have wizards who want to make
Society better for the magical Elite
versus those who want to make things
better for people who don't have any
magic in this series any child born
without a magic mark is required to be
handed over to the government and if a
parent was to hide their child to try
and protect them then they'd be guilty
of a serious crime on top of that even
if someone was born with magic but then
loses it for some reason even they need
to be handed over since magicless people
aren't allowed to mix with everyone else
the unfairness of the society is
something that none of the main
characters agree with and it's time to
do a quick rundown of what each of them
represent to start things off we have
mash burn dead who's a guy that spent
most of his life hitting the weights and
eating cream puffs years ago Mash was
one of the few humans born into the
world without a magic mark but instead
of of being turned over to the bureau
his adopted dad hid him away in a forest
to keep him safe ever since then he's
been following a consistent training
routine which his dad made him do so
that you know in the future he could
defend himself from Magic users now
without going into spoilers a series of
events take place that Force Mash a
person without any magic to try and
become the next Divine Visionary
although a task like that should be
impossible his muscles combined with his
Natural Instincts mean that he is able
to navigate through Easton even without
magic Talent when it comes to his
personality Mash has two sides to him
depending on the situation because in
the moments where he needs to be serious
he 100 reminds me of josro an example of
this is how he always stays completely
cool regardless of how bad things might
look and also how he's able to
creatively defeat his opponents in ways
that no one else would even think of he
also doesn't like to say too many words
but instead relies on short phrases to
Trash Talk his enemies and he only
really gets angry if someone hurts his
friends however although Mash
demonstrates high amounts of
intelligence during a fight in normal
circumstances he does lack a lot of
common sense and he won't realize things
that would be obvious to most people
part of the reason for this might be the
fact that he was raised separately from
other humans and so he's missing a lot
of the life experiences that most people
have one final thing to say about this
character is that he is completely
obsessed with eating green Bobs and
he'll carry one with him at pretty much
all times next up we have Lance Crown
who's a powerful double-line magic user
looking to become the next Divine
Visionary Lance comes from a relatively
well-known family who are famous for
their gravity magic and as a member of
House Adler he has a noble reason for
why he wants to change magic Society his
personality can be summarized as being
brave confident strong-willed and
protective over his sister moving on to
dot this guy is one of Mash's most
interesting friends and he's shown to
have a huge amount of magic potential
especially for someone who only has a
single line his explosion magic fits in
well with his fiery personality and he's
proven himself off time and time again
to have a ton of guts finally Finn and
lemon are the last two people in the
group and they both have a special
relationship with mash in lemon's case
she has a huge crush on him and
mistakenly believes that he agreed to
marry her while Finn is his roommate and
his first real friend although Finn is
the weakest in the group he can
sometimes be brave if it's you know to
help his friends and he also has an
intriguing relationship with his super
powerful older brother who goes to the
same school if any of you guys have seen
Yugo GX it is basically like the Cyrus
insane relationship where you have the
you know respected older sibling who
kind of you know doesn't seem to respect
the younger sibling that much anyhow in
terms of what to expect from the series
overall we need to remember that despite
the political and sometimes
philosophical topics that the show talks
about this is still a comedy first and a
battle shown in second one of the best
things about Marshall is watching other
characters react to Mash's insane Feast
of strength as he constantly Breaks the
Rules of magic science and life and
death another the great thing is the
World building because throughout the
series we fully get to see the inner
workings of the bureau the school
organized crime and other cool things
that make this series feel really full
the Headmaster of Easton is also a
strong Dumbledore type character with a
mysterious pass and even Mash himself
also has interesting things about his
backstory that will likely be hinted at
in the first season with that said I'll
be watching the show when it drops on
the 7th of April and I hope that this
video convinced at least some of you to
give it a go if you hadn't heard of it
until today until the next one peace out